été 2001 steven guilbeault parti c'est
par un coup d'éclat qui le fera
connaître du grand public à toronto de
membres de greenpeace n'ont pas hésité à
escalader la tour cn afin d'y déployer
une bannière protestant contre le
réchauffement de la planète mais son
souvenir le plus lointain d'engagement
pour l'environnement remonte à l'enfance
lorsque des arbres doivent être coupés
derrière chez lui pour construire des
maisons avec la permission de la mère
j'en ai choisi un fish je suis grimper
je suis resté là des heures et des
heures avant cette journée là cet art
brison populeux coupé alors
le début des années 90 ils font les ong
équiterre avec une autre figure de proue
du mouvement environnemental québécois
lors varidel steven représentait
vraiment le pragmatisme c'est quelqu'un
qui est en mode solution que peu peur de
faire des compromis ou si ce que peut
causer certaines frictions à certains
moments avec d'autres d'autres
écologistes qui jugeait que certains
compromis était peu est acceptable parmi
les premiers ministres de
l'environnement à prendre ensuite la
parole dans les années qui suivent il
est parfois le caillou dans la chaussure
des gouvernements qui ne s'engagent pas
suffisamment pour combattre les
changements climatiques comme au sommet
de kyoto aux états unis d'amérique sont
toujours pris en otage par le lobby des
combustibles fossiles et à copenhague
dimitri soudas ce l'attaché de presse de
stephen harper alors premier ministre du
canada l'accusent faussement d'être
l'auteur d'un canular
plusieurs vous veillez peut-être au sein
de l'appareil gouvernemental
est-ce qu'il est aussi courtisé par tous
les ordres de gouvernement pendant de
nombreuses années très très heureux
c'est finalement en 2019 qu'il répondra
à l'appel du libéral fédéral justin
trudeau deux ans plus tard il devient
ministre de l'environnement je ne veux
plus me mentir je prends la décision de
quitter le gouvernement
le saut en politique n'a pas toujours
souri aux environnementalistes
le français nicolas hulot rapidement
démissionné de ses fonctions de ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
nicolas hulot avait pas l'expérience du
travail
politique simone à faire ce travail là
depuis seulement deux décennies et dont
il est capable de travailler à
l'intérieur des institutions pour faire
avancer ces objectifs le passé militant
du nouveau ministre de l'environnement
ne rassure toutefois pas tout le monde
s'y met sur guilbault suivent les
politiques qu'ils appuyaient en tant que
militant
auparavant ça serait une 2h pour
l'économie canadienne steven guilbeault
participera pour la 19e fois à la
conférence des nations unies sur les
changements climatiques
mais pour la première fois ce sera en
tant que ministre de l'environnement ici
pascal racing junior du canada n'ont
rien